[Music]
are you asking me to move in you know
but it's a great idea what do you say
well she said yes and the Conners may be
in for another big shock should Darlene
move herself and the kids out of family
home yeah so who better than her TV
daughter and McKenney to tell me if
tonight's season finale also comes with
a big goodbye give me a juicy tease of
the season finale tonight there may be
an old familiar face that comes to the
Connors front door yep just sayin
and he might come with a big secret and
earlier in the season the show dealt
with the TV death of Roseanne now the
family is facing the possibility of Sara
Gilbert
Darlene moving away I mean everybody's
gonna have different reactions I think
that Darlene's is probably going to be
the hardest because she's been taking
care of Dan now and has taken over as
kind of the maternal role of the Connors
this series has been a hit for ABC and
there's hope the show will return next
fall Johnny Galecki has made guest
appearances as Emma's TV dad and who
knows could he become a regular now Big
Bang Theory is ending Johnny is
available more so would you like to see
possibly your TV dad be on the show more
yeah that would be so fun Johnny's so
awesome do you think there's a chance
that David and Darlene could end up back
together I love them together yeah me
too I think that they balance each other
out and they're just perfect for each
other
[Music]